no i don't think it's crazy at all
because jesus mary magdalene jesus was a
pen
so
really it's really a part of our
religion if i say i praise jesus and
when before the three days before jesus
rose it was only mary magdalene and
jesus mom who stood right there for him
to rise so it was his bottom [ __ ] and
his mom and it says if you look it up it
says in the bible um eventually it was
mary magdalene and mary magdalene in a
group of females a group of females
financially supporting jesus so jesus
had a whole stable and this was biblical
so i don't look at it crazy
you praise god but you're looking at
what i'm doing crazy and he used to do
it so they were trading goats and [ __ ]
probably like
all right trophy yeah trophy were you
from originally where'd you grow up um i
grew up in san diego escondido for like
a little bit and then i moved to the
inland empire tell me about your family
um i have a mom a dad my dad was always
really in and out of jail
he worked you know my mom was some work
too so like my family is really game
related type type of deal um
i really was raised by my mom and my
stepdad though
how'd you describe your childhood in
general
uh i'm not go i'm a leo so i don't want
to be the center of attention but i'll
say i was definitely the black sheep
like i was just always it was just
always something
i was always getting in trouble i was
always
doing something so i started really
retaliating like you know i'm not gonna
stay in this house like y'all keep me
here all the time so i'm out of here how
old are you now i'm from 18 i'm going to
be 19 on the 21st and you uh
you're attracted to the streets i mean
there's something about it that
yeah i'll say
like on some real stuff it's like
it's my piece really like when i'm
outside
that's just peaceful that stuff i don't
know
it's very it's
i don't know how to describe it like
i love the game though like most
definitely like i know this is what i
got like when i i don't have nobody for
real like that like i have a mom and a
dad but they situation they're not i
can't just go home like i want to go to
my house you don't have any family
support no like for
like i know when i hit that blade if i
don't have no money i don't know if i
have my id
i'm gonna have i'm gonna have i'm gonna
be taken care of i'm gonna have that
roof over my head like i don't know like
i just been always i always really had
to fend for myself in reality like so at
18 you're living where you're in a motel
yeah i'm god right now
and a little momo
do you have a uh a pen
yeah i do i have i have some folks
yeah and uh
you've been doing this for how long a
year so i've been with my he's my
turnout i've been with the same god and
did we have you know you have your
little battles in it but i left but i've
been with the same same man
you finished high school
no
that's so crazy it's crazy because i
finished i got all my credits like i i
was bad as hell i didn't do [ __ ] my
freshman to junior year my senior year i
went to like uh this church type of
ordeal school to get my credits back and
like
my basically my baby daddy passed away
and i just like i was done and it was in
covet too it would have been a
difference if i had to get up and go to
school but we had to finish it through
the computers like so it was like i just
didn't have the motivation to um do that
i have the time for it you have a child
yeah he's two
and you're raising him yeah in a motel
no he stays with somebody else he stays
with his god mom he's well taken care of
like while i'm working he doesn't he's
not around my lifestyle
are drugs at part of your life
weed just weed
you'll work how many hours typically
like through the night
yeah really i like uh
i'm big i don't like doing night time
i'll i'll do daytime [ __ ] for days i'll
bust through the daytime it's good
through the daytime it's a little safer
during the day right yeah i'll go
outside during the night but
pomona everywhere else i'm outside all
night i like i'm outside yeah yeah
figaro is another
figure is a whole nother scene isn't it
the
[Music]
ghetto and tell me about the guys that
you'll
have as customers
oh um
they're cool
you know you meet some
you you there's all types of customers
like what do you call them tricks or
jobs you know tricks john's whatever um
if i call my regulars i'm like friend
i'm calling a friend but they still know
to stay in that category but i'm not
just keep calling you a trick like i
might learn your name
stuff like that but they're they're
they're cool i mean it's cool it's
really like i remember when i first got
introduced to it like
because i was really always curious
about it i'm not gonna lie i was scary
so like i'm like when i was a minor i
used to be on other sites and i used to
be trying to get the the tricks and
everything but i should be like i'm
gonna do a platonic relationship like no
sex so i used to be trying to do get
sugar daddies and [ __ ] so like
the little five minutes and [ __ ] like
that it's real like you just gotta be
when i get the little seductive [ __ ] out
the way i don't always be so nice with
him either but it's fast it's easy
and you find it easy
yeah i feel like it's just how you act
with them it's how you it's how you are
as a person um i'mma know who car not to
get into i mean i had one bad situation
happen to me like within this whole year
but what happened i got raped and robbed
yeah arizona
by a mexican he was in a work car and i
was scared i was paranoid for like
three weeks i was like i'm not dating no
mexicans like i'm not [ __ ] with them
they're crazy that'll put you out of
business i'm figaro huh that'll put you
out of business on figaro street yeah
but it wasn't even in fake so
i never had nothing crazy happen to me
on fig like for real
what's your favorite kind of job
trick um
i feel like the fetish ones like the
ones who like to give you massages
and really pay you like just to massage
you because they're really getting off
or the ones like that that like to get
off while you're just like
doing you like you could be in there
smoking doing your hair on your phone
like maybe put a little you don't even
have to have sex yeah like i like those
dates you feel me i like those days but
the ones that we have to have sex i just
get them in and out of there like
how does this affect you emotionally
um i feel like
i couldn't i don't know i couldn't tell
you that because i don't
know if it affects me emotionally i feel
like i've been through a lot so i kind
of learned
as a kid
just to you know like mash it off like
just
was there any like sexual abuse or
anything like that in your childhood
no
i wouldn't call it's whatever
everybody goes through something like
you know so a family gonna call it a
kiss cousins when family get like that
but your little cousin situation
incident and [ __ ] like that
but
i never been like raped
was there another life you wanted
another do you have any dreams of doing
something else with your life
uh
or was this your goal
it is for some girl
like i'm trying to think and it's like
i'll always binge like
you know city girl like just getting the
money
giving it so are you addicted to this
fast money lifestyle it's the money yeah
because i have a lot of clients that's
like oh what do you like and i'll tell
you like what makes me arouse and even
make you feel like i'm into a date is
like the money the money it just it's
the drive it's just like it's not the
sex no if it was playing cards it made
you money you'd be playing cards yeah
and it's like when you have those guys
that's just talking a hundred dollars
and stuff like that
it's like that's still like
like
but when they talk more money it's just
like okay let's get into it like what
you want to do what you want to do what
you want to do
is there any other
is there any going back to a
a real love relationship for you or is
it always going to be money's going to
be tied into the equation somehow i feel
like even even with your personal life
um have you ever been a left before
oh yeah once
and was that
yeah i was in love with my best friend
so that wasn't about money no i wasn't
about no money that was love i was
i wish i would again
i just can't
so so it's possible you could meet
somebody and fall in love and it
wouldn't be about the money
yeah
if they don't still accept my lifestyle
though because like i wouldn't put my
lifestyle i wouldn't be doing this like
because i know i have a son and stuff
like that i would want to create a
family of my own or whatever the case
may be
but
i must still i'ma still be i still want
to break break a trick i'm still
breaking tricks so
but what if what if you met a richard
gere type who's going to you know sweep
you off your feet and take care of you
so you won't have to do this anymore no
you're still going to do it yeah
like i wish i would i can't
i didn't
could have been there already if we
wanted to take that route but
why would i i feel like honestly on god
why would i let you come sleep me first
of all i need my own i need my own like
i need to know that i work for i got it
in it because mine's hours or whatever
but
it's like um
no why would i do that because like if i
could get in a controlling situation
like because it's like you really depend
on this person so when you're mad at me
i can't go get my nails done or no i
can't do what i usually do when you're
not mad at me like
no and nine times tonight i mentioned
when you were a trick so
if you think you're gonna come sweep me
off my feet
like i'm gonna be a wife or whatever the
hell and you gonna be tricking on
somebody else
like
what's the trick always a trick what
have you learned about men
they
you know there's they're
i don't know
they're creatures that i just haven't
um
i haven't understood them yet i haven't
got to that part i don't understand them
you've only been doing this a year so
huh you've only been doing this a year a
year yeah oh but i i i say off my
situation i've gained like um he's i
really grew maturely like what's that
like i've matured a lot he's taught me a
lot just about life uh if you put the
game aside like really who i am as a
person today like he had a big big big
big part in that like very big part huh
you're pam yeah yeah
what was the best example of a loving
relationship you saw as a kid
between a man and a woman
i honestly i don't know
i i know grandma's grandparents my
grandma she always had different my
grandma was always in my ear telling me
like you need to be with somebody who's
gonna give you one like she she's like a
rich white man like that's what the
ordeal is that's what the deal is i
never understood as a kid when i grew up
like i started taking notes your
grandmother told you this
yeah my grandma would always tell me
like my grandma would never i don't
think she ever told me go
get somebody you love like if she's
always like what are they pockets
looking like what's that pockets looking
like like
what [ __ ] what he talking about like
what is his money looking like like i
never seen my granny even be in love
talk about a love she had
like about
it's two
i could say
off top of my head that like her little
friends
that she have coming in and stuff
does this work affect your self-esteem
positively or negatively no i feel like
uh you guys are always rolling up
anything beautiful
yeah if anything
i could say maybe positively but before
this lifestyle i've been you are you're
always confident very
you know so
all day more important you love our
money
loyalty
good answer yeah
what was the best thing that's ever
happened to you out there so far
oh
you got into a sugar daddy situation yet
yeah i did and it turned left he okay
they always do yeah it was crazy so he
was buying me i'm thinking i'm top-notch
like he's getting balenciaga [ __ ] uh he
get it was a i don't know camaro or a
charger long story short
it only lasted like with a good with the
good month it was a great month
until whoever his wife was done with
and they got back together he wants the
car back like all types of crazy action
he gave you a car yeah and i didn't i
couldn't keep it
so how much money do you give you a day
it was like he'll give me like 15 like a
he like i would it would even be how
much money because it'll start off like
okay we're trying to get the hour for
like 600 or whatever 500
because he wasn't he was he was my uh
black he was black and i don't really
date blacks but we really didn't have
sex he was like a cocaine so what his
ordeal was he would just keep bumping
his coke and he would just want me to
dance in front of him naked so i'd be
walking around his house naked for like
hours
so that's when it just came to breaking
like okay if you want this extra hour
i'm gonna need this at your 600. but if
you want to do the three hours we could
just go ahead and do 15 like we could
make it i think i did i'm not going i
think i did like four hours with him and
i was like we could do 15 but he had
money like he was a marine some [ __ ]
like that retired he had a lot of like
he had good money i went to his house
and stuff like that
he would
yeah he was good
what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you
um
i don't feel like i feel like the
hardest part would do i mean i think the
hardest part would be
the assumptions that people like how
people view you like that don't really
know about their lifestyle like you're
very misunderstood yeah like even how
your family how
like when i started this i very grew
like distant with a lot of people that i
thought was going you saw me we're going
to go somewhere in life but
it's like when they just look at you so
differently how people treat you to like
they judge you harshly yeah like the
people that you may have thought was
your friends how people come up come at
you like
yeah like it's crazy because it's like
i'm the i'm getting the money but you
think i'm a trick or something like
everybody think i'm a trip
like
it's irritating like you're being played
yeah i fly every last like it's like
it's a benefit now
by the lifestyle or by your pimp or by
whoever yeah it's like just by the
lifestyle like you know that um you just
because you know i like you're
brainwashed
yeah no i'm not brainwashed but i feel
like they'd be trying to brainwash me or
something like i don't [ __ ] know but
just because i'm out here selling myself
or whatever the case may be that don't
mean that i owe anybody anything and i'm
not even just talking about a pimp
situation i'm talking about just like
family and just you know
etc
i mean it's a crazy lifestyle do you
ever just stand back and realize what
you're doing is
nuts yeah like i we
like with my friend my hp i'm like
on figaro street everyone's doing it so
it doesn't seem so crazy but if you
oh no i don't think no i don't think
it's crazy at all
because jesus mary magdalene jesus was a
pen
so
really it's really a part of our
religion if i say i praise jesus and
when before the three days before jesus
rose it was only mary magdalene and
jesus mom who stood right there for him
to rise so it was his bottom [ __ ] and
his mom and it says if you look it up it
says in the bible um eventually it was
mary magdalene and mary magdalene in a
group of females a group of females
financially supporting jesus so jesus
had a whole stable and this was biblical
so i don't look at it crazy
you praise god but you're looking at
what i'm doing crazy and he used to do
it so
they were trading goats and [ __ ]
probably like not
how we exchanging money and [ __ ] but
yeah
do you believe in karma
yeah
how does karma play out in this
lifestyle of yours
uh
just like
if you like you think you're gonna get
up on somebody
think you might just rob it whatever
i'm not gonna say not rob you know but
you think you hit and then
i don't know next week you
on the phone talking about something you
just got robbed
it goes around comes around yeah yeah
play fair
do you have friends
like
one two
is it difficult to be around so many
people that you don't trust
yeah now
yeah like i've been like somebody i've
trusted
long story short like
uh so i really thought i trusted this
girl and she
i woke up and all my money and
everything was gone i could have been
done but i mean i didn't have so much
money i had money around her before and
that she never took so why would i think
you would take money this time
so i feel like i don't trust nobody i'll
investigate a car like what are you like
i just want to let you know you're not
going to kidnap me a part of no set up
nothing
like i don't trust nobody what do you
girls talk about on the street when
you're just out there like on 69th but
then when there's 10 girls i don't
uh
i don't really like socializing because
i don't like females i don't like to be
really friendly it's get it gets messy
you say you talk one inch just about
like
girls
blah blah blah i don't know it just gets
around too fast everybody know i don't
want nobody in my business
so
but i feel like we're talking it's
probably gonna be like girl
this [ __ ] is dry
like
you might start talking
i don't know some girls start
fantasizing about they folks like girl
my daddy and then you got the girls
that's out there like
i'm i just need to make this much money
and choose a feed and i'm out of here
like i'm leaving him so i try not to be
like those girls because there's really
nothing
that i ever heard
is getting talked about like for real
out there like
worth time it's just [ __ ] are there
a lot of pimps that like to try to steal
you away
still you wait they are annoying like
yeah
they be talking like shut up
like we're not going nowhere with this
yeah it's pretty crazy down there yeah
are you worried about the future your
child's gonna have with you living this
lifestyle no um because
when
he looks back at it
where where i'm going to be
in like
five years or whatever my son's gonna
have a great life so i feel like even if
he did find out i would or ever came to
me i would definitely let him know like
tell him the truth because it's nothing
but i feel like he's not gonna have
nothing to
i know everything i didn't have as a
child like
just financially and emotionally so how
i'm going to be with him i feel like
he's going to understand like i don't
think he's going to be tripping i don't
worry about
nothing i don't post my son on social
media that i'd be posting naked on i
don't i don't do [ __ ] like that so
i got i'ma get everything in order
so i don't have to worry about his
future you know are you saving money
yeah something like that
but it gets gets hard out here
so yeah
and tell me trophy what's the most
important thing you've learned in your
18 years
um
i think the most important thing i
learned is really to be honest is just
loyalty like
the loyalty you can have with somebody
could take you a long way
like really out here you don't have
nobody in reality even if it's your
family like you could really find
somebody on the street to give a [ __ ]
about you more than
yo mom whoever like you feel me so it's
like i feel like the most important
thing i really learned in 18 years is
just how you are as a person
and
how to keep your character like you know
how to really just move as a person
and move with the universe because the
universe works for you you know so i
think one thing i have learned
is like
to live stress feet for a lot of free
like really live stress via sounds i
don't know might be childish kitty i
don't know but i don't know if y'all
watch dr cb but like you have to live
when you live stress free and you just
out here like okay your goal is instead
of i'm going to go outside and be like
okay i'm going to make a band yeah you
can do that but i'm going to go outside
i'm going to be happy i'm going to have
this good energy and then like that's
when everything
that you want in the universe is going
to come to you like when you're not
stressing on something or stuff like
that i don't know
excellent all right trophy thank you so
much for sharing your story all right
thank you mark out there all right i
will i was gonna walk up and leave
you